PROFESSOR: So now we're
ready to synthesize
our knowledge of
airborne transmission
in a well-mixed room and
epidemiological models
to arrive at a safety
guideline to limit
the indoor airborne
spread of COVID-19,
or, more generally, other
respiratory pathogens.
Existing guidelines
limit one parameter
that might be important.
For example, social
distancing limits the spacing
between people,
which can be defined
by the average area per occupant
for example, to a minimum
of, say, 6 feet or 1 meter.
Other rules, for
example, adopted here
in the state of Massachusetts,
limit all gatherings
to be no larger than
25 persons indoors.
There also are recommendations
from heating and ventilation
societies that may recommend
we increase the fresh air
change rate to six or higher.
In the UK, for example,
the fresh air flow rate
might be prescribed to 10
liters per second per person
or other such numbers.
Also the time that
an infected person
is in the presence
of susceptible people
might be limited
to say, 15 minutes.
That's involved in the
definition of a contact
here in the United States.
So what we will see is
that it's really not
possible to write down a
realistic guideline that
bounds any one quantity, because
there will always be situations
where you either
are too conservative
or are not careful enough
in bounding that quantity,
because these qualities
are all related.
So, for example,
25 persons might
be perfectly safe in
a very large space
for a very short amount of time
with very high ventilation.
But take those 25 persons and
seal them into a small tent,
breathing each other's
air for 24 hours with very
little ventilation, it's a
completely different situation.
And the same holds
for the distance,
or the time, or the flow
rates, everything is mixed.
And then what about
other variables
that we don't
explicitly control?
Like relative humidity
or filtration efficiency,
if you're using filters
to filter the air.
Or if you're wearing masks.
The quality of the masks,
how well does that come in?
How about the
volume of the space?
It's not just the flow
rate, but it's also
the geometry, even the area,
or the length of the space.
So somehow all these
variables must be related,
and the goal of this chapter
is to derive that relationship
for the case of a
well-mixed room, where it's
a unique universal guideline.
And to parameterize this
specifically for COVID-19,
by looking at a variety of
superspreading events for which
enough data is available
that we can make
a reasonable and consistent
inference of the infectiousness
of exhaled breath.